chinese scientists have announced their
development of the most powerful quantum
computer in the world
it works 100 trillion times faster
than the fastest supercomputers out
there president xi jinping has said
research and development in quantum
science
is an urgent matter of national concern
and the country has invested heavily in
this technology
spending billions in recent years it has
become a world leader in the field
to the untrained eye it may not look
like much
but this is now the world's most
powerful computer
twenty years in the making zhu zheng is
the brainchild of china's top scientists
who are now asserting their dominance in
the race for quantum supremacy
zhang has shown outstanding quantum
computational capability
we are planning to use it for quantum
chemistry research
and graft theory's combinatorics
research
it comes little more than a year after
google unveiled sycamore
their own quantum computer google
researchers
have achieved an incredible breakthrough
in quantum computing
their machine needed seconds to perform
tasks which conventional systems would
require thousands of years to do
the chinese team say their light based
technique is 10 billion times faster
than google's
it's a remarkable achievement it's a
milestone
in the development of these
intermediate scale quantum computers it
is still
early days but scientists hope their
achievement will lead to the technology
unlocking rapid advancements in
encryption and pharmaceutical
analysis we have demetrius and galactus
a scientist with the center for quantum
technologies and alex capri of the
hinrich foundation
both are joining us from singapore
demetrius i want to
start with you why does this news out of
china
matter well it matters because a massive
a massive scientific breakthrough first
of all
and being a scientist i have to
highlight that and it's the first
time or actually the second time to be
exact that we have a quantum computer a
prototype quantum computer
clearly outperforming classical
computers first time was last year
in the google labs in santa barbara and
this is the
second time using a very different
technology based on photos that
a similar experiment has been made now
how will the use of this technology
impact people's lives
demetrius well we are we are talking
about
a completely different way of computing
impossible
things to compute classically so
although this demonstration has not
achieved that it's it's it's a
mathematical problem that probably has
been solved
if you had a classical computer to do
that it would take a few millions or
hundreds of thousands of years further
down the line we hope that quantum
computing will allow us to do
impossible problems these days in
biology in drug design
in in financial optimization in root
optimization and
and in environment as well so at the
moment we don't have the computational
power to tackle
these very important problems that
affect society in very different ways
including what we're living through drug
design these days
very interesting i'm going to turn to
alex the chinese government has funneled
a lot of money into scientific research
why is that
well look this is part of a much broader
uh
techno-nationalist um approach to
to advancing uh you know chinese
interests when it comes to
economics national security obviously
geopolitics
uh and and you know this is a major
priority whether we're talking about the
made in china 2025 plan
uh semiconductors of course is big uh
quantum computing is an area obviously
they've been putting a lot of money into
so this is a very important um aspect
of the of the overall
trajectory that the that the chinese
communist party
is striving for demetrius from a
scientific perspective is this china's
sputnik moment there's been so much news
going on i kind of feel as if this
quantum development kind of got lost
amidst all the coveted stuff and
everything but should we be paying more
attention to this
from a scientific perspective that's a
very good question well it's like
it is in a sense it is in a sense and
now sputnik it's out there
it doesn't do much it just blips but it
is there
again it's not the first time google in
the west has done it first
and many other scientific labs around
the world are working towards the same
uh demonstration of an impossible task
for cluster computers
it will take us time before we go from
this blip blip that
sputnik was doing to something like
video calls by the satellites and
if i want to do the analogy to the space
race but we are entering
um and already there the quantum race in
that sense
um in many different yep yeah
well one thing that i i'm trying to wrap
my head around
is just how much bigger of a quantum
leap
this chinese development has been
compared to the google one
one of the things that i've been reading
is that actually the google one wasn't
really
quite the you know um it didn't count
somehow
um help us sort of get a sense of just
how
much more technologically advanced this
development has been
well i wouldn't say it's more
technologically advanced it's different
this is based on photons the google one
was based on superconducting
cubits very different technologies at
the moment we don't know
the the field is so early stages we
don't know which one will really be
the final technology that will implement
quantum computing
um i would put it at equal footing in a
sense
uh the the billions of years
versus 10 000 years in the google that's
kind of the the projected thing
but on the other hand the the chinese
one was not reprogrammable you cannot
really adjust it the way it is
to run different algorithms except this
specific problem
so i would say both are really equally
equally exciting for the field
definitely from the scientific side
alex demetrius has walked us through
some of the applications of this
technology what is the perspective of
this from someone like you who studies
technonationalism
and the competition we're seeing between
the us and china and what is techno
nationalism
well look techno nationalism is
essentially when nation states
uh ascribe um the the
the power and the prowess if you will
of their local firms their local
champions if you will
to national security uh economic
stability and strength
and social stability as well so we're
seeing all three of those
in this emerging u.s china technology
hybrid cold war
um so i think you know i would i would
go back to say that that
the you know to put the sputnik moment
uh in historical context
you know the the united states soviet
union
um i would think that that sputnik
moment would be a bit more significant
um you know to jump forward now to this
announcement
uh that we've just had from from the
chinese um i think
the the reverse of that is going to be a
second moon shot which has really been
underway right i think
the united states now uh and its
european allies and other allies are now
going to start focusing
on greater emphasis on r d um
you know greater emphasis on
public-private partnerships
around making progress with you know all
the
uh the the you know industries
uh that are emerging and foundational
for this next
this next century um so i think there
really is
um there's significance in that it will
it'll be a catalyst for that
but i don't really i wouldn't call this
you know a a historic moment in the
context of sputnik
alex the pentagon through the research
arm darpa launched a program to advance
quantum
computing earlier this year it feels a
little bit behind the curve
considering the development that we've
just seen how would you assess the u.s
china sort of technological race that
we're seeing alex
so so what we will see melissa is we
will see more and more r
d be shifted under the military
industrial complex so stuff that might
have been happening
at you know r d that might have been
taking place
exclusively at companies and maybe at
universities and specialized
institutions
you will see more of that being shifted
under the military
uh sort of tent if you will
demetrius angalakis and alex capri thank
you so much for joining us
you